[Music]
oh my god this is so similar to the
table i have
of course it is i wouldn't have no i
mean like we got the flag in there i've
got that too okay so
i went down i was like what i want to do
so like the original attempt was i
wanted to put
here's the so it's grouped by country
and what i wanted was the australian
flag next to australia
and the austrian flag next to austria et
cetera et cetera oh yeah i got you got
you yeah who didn't get it to work
oh yeah the reason is
is because it's like a a real group and
it's really hard to like change the
content in a row group yeah so i
couldn't target the row group so that
got really frustrating was i couldn't do
that and then it turns out flags are
really hard
to work with
and i got very lucky because someone oh
gosh um let me pull up his name so did
you go to the table gallery to get some
pointers
no
because like there's some good
flags in those tables
that's okay you got to the answer so i
i'm you know so
dr liam bailey whoever you are thank you
you are oh
like this oh this is like timely it just
got published this is fresh just got
published and i was like this is what i
want you know i want a flag so anyway
the dreaded tip that's all the dreaded
things
oh my god this was about a table in an
academic paper it's it's oh yeah i can
see all about how much they really like
gt so it was really it was
rarely do i find something that is
almost verbatim what i'm looking for but
i was able to just like scroll down and
be like where did you put in the flags
fantastic so then i learned about the
country code yeah
so yeah so this this saved me but like
we're talking
because i think maybe for a context
right i don't know how much time you
spend on i mean you work with gt but i i
use their time yeah three or four hours
on a table and i spent three or four
hours getting the emotes the emoji to
work
oh sorry i didn't know it was that crazy
no no no it's it's tough because you
have to do a few things have the files
yeah available and then you have to like
use text transform and then like that
other image function
yeah then once you have those three
things in place it's not so it's not bad
no it's so it was like a huge learning
experience so my little thing with this
table was the scope creep because i was
like i'm gonna do this and then i'm
gonna do this and there were so many
different things that i wanted to do
with this table
um
that i just i didn't get to all of them
but yeah so here's here's where i left
off
um and like styling wise i think it it's
like not quite there but it's close
no it's really good i like the title
that's that's an image right like
eurovision song oh that's font
oh
that was so much oh yeah you're right
because i see the emoji in the middle
that looks so much like the real like
i'm not not real but like there's a
bunch of like eurovision like logos yeah
search and that's like that's really
close
yeah so it looks like what is the fonts
and then i tried to find it in google
fonts and so the closest i could find
was something called rock salt which is
i mean let me open my little outline
here i've had to start outlining all the
funny
that's a good it's a good thing to do
totally good thing yeah so your euro and
then i put cause i then i was like yeah
i put a heart in there and i was like oh
it's all marked down so here's where i
can use the package so i'm ultimately
like i'm i'm happy with how far i got
but then this is not finished i did
start down this route and i swear to god
i'm gonna
what what are we planning on doing
oh i see redoing you're you're like
so
you got some shiny stuff happening you
got that this is a shiny table it's a
shiny taste this is awesome okay this is
great this is great
so it's not quite where i want it like
this was what i was working on this
morning was like how can i just get
a table that you know responds to a
couple of different inputs right yeah
this is brilliant
uh but yeah it was really cool to make
but you know like
there's a beautiful gt well beautiful in
progress gt table that is
responsive to different inputs which i
thought was cool so yeah this is great
basically it's like a reporting table
and you can imagine like doing this for
anything you just have to have like the
framework in place i guess yeah yeah and
so the code for this
wasn't too bad i
i started playing with pins i made a
whole bunch of
coding
coding things that need to be fixed up
yeah
hang on i got a cat running across
literally everything right now
um
so yeah i fixed up a bunch of things i'm
not sure this is the most effective way
to do it but i did just take essentially
the data table
made it reactive
um built the gt table just from that
reactive insight
yeah
range
not bad okay once you put it that way
this is
it's like two or three steps basically
right
yeah so it's basically what you need is
you need a data frame that's going to
respond to input so you need a reactive
data frame
and what i basically you know this is
pretty straightforward i wanted it to
filter the resulting data frame based on
the artist country which is what you're
grouped by
and then the rank so just
right one two or three so set that up as
a filter set that up as a reactive and
then you call it as a reactive data
frame before you pipe it into your gt
table
nice
that's cool
yeah that was that was something where i
was like i feel like this is easier than
it should be
this is kind of cool so you set your
choices
and
that's cool because you keep being safe
but you're just like limited to like
things you know are there like one to
three yeah yeah
filtered one to three and there's
different ways you could do this like
with the numeric input but i was like
let's just use select eyes and see what
happens i mean you can you don't even
have to do
a selected to start you can just kind of
um
right so you can start with just a blank
table and then i think there's something
that could be done
you know obviously to clean this up a
little bit
um
this is called like a multi-select so
those are like the the countries of like
where they are
this is any country oh i see being in
the host country yes exactly no
so this is any country that has had an
artist
oh got it okay great so it has nothing
to do with like they're winners or or
not yeah
so no there's two different things so
here's so your host country
is what
let me explain
of course yeah someone who has never
seen eurovision here's what i know the
host country is where the event is yeah
yeah and so then this is where the
artist is from oh okay okay this is why
it's kind of confusing with the flags
because it's like oh it was held in
austria and then these are like that's
there's there's some
weird stuff so basically
cesar conchita and udo are all from
austria
but this was the year and this is
it's tough because like
i ran into that exact same thing like
there's like two sets of countries per
line
and so you really want to make it like
especially like you know just like one
each one's a year so like you have to
really spell out like how do you make it
so like people don't get like
uh misled thinking like this is the
where they are the winners from and this
is where the [ __ ] you know like the
contest was held
yeah so i think there's
there's definitely a clearer way like
this still needs some work to make it a
little bit more clear like to make it
very clear actually as to what you're
looking at but i was pretty happy with
how far i got yeah it was amazing
there's no animations
i can't even find it i have a piece of
paper with all the things that i was
going to do in this table and so i was
going to get these like beautifully
styled links that take you to you know
and i'm pretty sure this is where we're
going with yours like no it's actually
it's actually tough to have links
because like there's
i guess they only go so far back maybe
they do in the dsm i'm not sure oh
i don't know if like all the previous
like pre-internet obviously since this
thing goes so far back that's a good
question there's pages for all these
things
yeah so
that was one thing i was like oh that's
like i finally decided like adding in
links would be my really really nice to
have so it was like okay one get the
flags two get it in a shiny app three
i wanted because you can get links to
the artist which i i thought was cool
with that from the artist page you can
actually get a youtube link yeah through
their song and then i was like oh that
would be really cool and then i was like
what if you could also embed that
somehow in the shiny app so you could
like
pull something up um
the coolest thing would be like you
hover over like
a row and it plays the song oh my gosh
like next level or something i didn't do
it but i'm just saying like that's an
idea hey there's an idea you just play
the song
do it just plays a song yeah that would
be really cool so like i feel like also
out of all the data sets we've looked at
this was the first one where it's like
there's so many different things you
could do
with this data set like it's about like
a really good table data yeah
great data set great table who can
answer anything more like this
i feel like whatever you're about to
show
so as you can see it's it's a bit long
there's some stuff in there but should i
just run the whole thing they're just
like all right let's see it i want to
see
what's this
it's going to run it's going to appear
here
i'll expand this out
oh my god
i know i know it's a little bit i got
little mini videos little tiny videos
they're like little gifts
so you know no sound but still like you
can't sound it'd be like a cacophony of
sound
check this out i didn't go too far back
because you know like i want to tell you
just
even water oh yeah yeah exactly and i
did i did what you do i i i did some
video editing
i got some source material
and i just said okay let's uh let's make
you some gifts let's
let's brew some gifts so i use gifski
okay manually i didn't do an r because i
you know i don't want to do more r for
that sort of thing so i just took
i screen captured a bunch of videos off
youtube i basically pirated some youtube
and uh yeah it was great the results are
awesome look at this you get like you
get a feel for like what happened in the
final sort of thing
um you know it's really nice
like look at all this it's like can i
zoom in no i can't zoom in oh well oh
yeah so this is like what you were
talking about where right you could get
the gif preview but then like hover over
and then you get kind of yeah that'd be
like super nice like that's that's
pretty cool and uh yeah these are really
good they're mostly like uh the videos
from like the final because like
eurovision hosts all these for some
reason for this one i got like the music
video and it's just a naked guy in water
so i wasn't too happy about that
wait i was like your header is changing
colors wait go fast okay check this out
it's basically animated yeah so i
thought like you know get some flash
going you know like yes
you know this is where i started i was
like
playing background oh it's making that
made
just names of songs oh let's get some
video in there i don't know how did you
do that like all right okay let me show
you i'll choose code okay so check this
out
so
and just scoot this off to the side
because we see enough okay so basically
uh yeah get the data that's just a thing
i have another file fine
uh so yeah i have a bunch of
so the logo i i took that from wikimedia
it's nice because it's an svg and
transparent background
it's nice to have
okay so that's what i got there uh okay
so the table i'll just run through this
and bring this down here so i did a ton
of like deep wiring like beforehand
yeah i didn't want to but i felt like i
had to so so check this out there's a
table like on the end it's pretty
stripped down
um but the key thing here is like i have
like a whole directory maybe you have
the same thing like these country
flags as spgs
where'd you get yours
data.world
okay yeah wherever you got them you know
like
you just you do have to do i got this on
github github just a big old directory
full of like these uh
three by four flags they also have one
by one versions
uh but they're svgs and like uh you can
totally use them so i put that directory
inside the files folder where this lives
uh i did some weird things like make
this all capitalized just to have some
differentiation between like the city
name and the country name not because i
really like all caps uh it was just like
you know underneath and
even a font because so there's the flags
so i did the same thing text transform
here's the flags so if i just run this
this is actually kind of cool i'm gonna
run this by itself
there we go
yeah
it's in a separate column
and come in here i'll show you some cool
tricks later about how you can like put
these together but preserve like the
column name starting here
uh but anyways so the the videos are
actually in a folder
so eurovision videos i just made a bunch
of gifs and i call them by the year okay
that way i can copy the year to a
separate um
like column and then like change it to
have like
gif in the end um
does that even work
uh how do you even do that
oh i i know because i add gift at the
end okay right here so i didn't have to
do anything here so basically text
transform the same way you can still use
local image because like a gif even
though it's animated is just an image
so it'll still do its thing so if i run
this just like up to there
and i expand it there they are
sort of in its protoform
uh and yeah there's the years so let's
kind of keep going
so i didn't like uh
for some reason i didn't like the video
being here so i moved it over
these are just things you do to adjust
things
yeah
so now it's going to be over
there on this side and then like tell us
on the very end because i want you know
like the videos to be there and then
like this is like left aligned
these titles
otherwise this is all caps i think
that's a mistake but or it's the name of
the song
i think i looked at it in wikipedia it
was just like toy like lowercase o
lowercase y i think it's just like
we just got some bad data here
uh sorry
so then i did like this calls merge
things to do um
the host city and the host country so
it's just like this
you can totally add a line break and
then it takes so long because these
videos
you have like that okay so now we're
going to change the column labels i do
this all the time i'm going to combine
that with like the font and making them
all caps
just in the interest of saving some time
here
so we're getting pretty close
a bunch of options to change colors
uh
and what did i do here oh yeah cell text
to be the smaller
okay we're getting there
there we go so background color i want
to make it like a dark color because you
know like these happen at night i want
to evoke
tonight i didn't quite get there because
it's not dark enough but
that's okay i think this is pretty good
it's kind of like a middle ground
uh column widths i set those all because
i want to be like super
i want to leave just the right amount of
space between each column like where
like the longest word
or
phrase ends we have a little bit of
space so it's kind of
super nice that way yeah okay and more
okay
okay here's a cool thing see how count
or it's actually country is like cut off
yeah because another column there so any
size yeah exactly when you size all
these columns things will get cut off
because now the table sees that okay
these are precisely all the widths of
each column we're not going to like mess
around anymore these are going to be the
widths any text you have it's going to
be cut off but no you have a choice you
can like use oracle x visible
on that column country emoji because
that's actually still called like the
column was country emoji
so if you do this check this out this is
a nice little trick there's always like
a solution like a way out of your like
weird things so i didn't have the
merchandise two columns i just did this
i just sized the columns and this just
peeks over
here which is totally fine because
there's no i took out the column name
anyways
see it's totally gone
uh yeah
country there you go
okay there's more i changed the font
here i want these are santiles i want to
be a sort of like you know scripty
because you know like you think of like
lyrics and writing things it's kind of
like a little more evocative if you have
like a script font so i change it from
the d from the font in the table to this
uh square peg
font in google fonts
i made extra large because this is like
a really abnormally small font yeah when
it renders it's like super tiny it's
like why okay so i just made it x large
bump that up
okay so much more uh padding which is in
the vertical direction i sort of like
tightened things up so i made like half
the amount of padding so now it's even
right here we can sort of see like
everything fits
just you can see euphoria which is great
before you couldn't
okay here's the title uh i did the thing
where i took that svg which i stole
i just installed i borrowed it
i don't know anyways i got this i'm
putting a line break because it sounds
like this this is going to be html right
here
and then we're doing some like i mean a
div
and i put the winners through the years
the reason why i put a div in id is
because i want to change it later in
some css stuff below which you can see
right here
okay so we're getting there
okay this will put in that large title
okay same background
as before but as you know we've it's
different in the end
okay source note because i just wanna
call out that i got this from tuesday
and i always wanna
say like you know
thank you ty tuesday for providing this
data
it's really amazing thing you're doing
okay this is a this is the part that's
really tough um
because this is just like messing around
with css
yeah and my process for doing this is i
just look at something i don't like
i just do a inspect element
and then like once i'm on the element
and i may not be right on it i think i
am here
but if you're not you can use this it's
a little bit tricky in our studio you
start to cover around and then find the
thing if you find the background you can
click onto it
then go back to this and you can like
mess around in here with different
things like
background
versions red
it just changes things yeah so once you
know the trick to do that you can really
mess around in like these dev tools
and then
as long as you have like some sort of id
or way of like knowing what this is in
this case it's
what i do i put a background on
uh sorry
where to put it
gt heading
because oh geez uh if you look here gt
heading is right there class
so i'm like oh okay so that's the way to
change it so basically i put a table id
as well it's sort of a good practice to
do that in your gt call you have an id
argument
if you stick something in there you can
do this and if you have multiple tables
on a page it won't mess up the other
tables you're just like fixing it just
one table that's why an id for a table
is good
um but yeah gt heading and then like i
put this stuff this i did not invent i
went to a page which is like add like an
animated background
you basically pick a few colors you
change the angle a bit there's and then
there's some like css you can copy
so i stuck it in here and made sure it
worked with gt heading
and that's it
that's how i did the background being
all
animated
[Music]
and then i did a bunch more stuff like
um
see i know it's like this is in red
where it should be white so i changed
that to white somewhere
uh right here
the only anchor tag we have
which is basically this just color white
text underline position under that makes
the line a little bit
lower lower yeah
and then the source note this whole area
i found it was kind of too scrunched in
so i just add some padding on the top
and bottom
to compensate
oh here's the cool thing you can do um
and it's hard to show because um
okay i really want to show you this
because it's amazing okay i'm gonna take
this out
and i'll copy it back in i'm gonna show
you the before and after
because i found that
this was like way too low this whole
title and that's after just putting like
you know like the svg and then like a
line break
than this but you can totally adjust
that and the way i found it is just to
inspect elements
again doing that trick where you use
this right here because you may not be
right on top of the thing
there we go uh div title text
because i had that did with the id
once you're on there you can like mess
around with things and the thing i
messed around with was
this right here
uh not well font size is one thing but
this is important thing padding bottom
that'll push it up
margin top if you put a negative number
that'll sort of like
push it
more up like it'll take away the space
okay like right like the natural
space between the two it's gonna yeah
it's like super super weird that it
works but it's a great thing essentially
if you look at this right here see that
right here
this goes way down yeah uh you can like
break through that you can like move it
like a div below that up into that space
just by using the negative
yeah exactly yeah if you use margin as
well if you use padding it does not work
with your margin it allows you to use
negative values and you can just like
you can rescue your your bad formatting
yeah there's so many things but yeah i
did these things and
i even included a margin here for this
whole thing this image
i think that's right no hang on i
changed the svg width right here
that's this i think image was
this right here i found the flags were
if you took this out
there's some really details here but
like these are like little front end
things yeah if you're not totally
satisfied with the way it looks i found
the flags to be like a little bit too
high like each and every one of them see
how the like
the distance between them is like living
off
yeah that's what i did here with this
and these are the only things which are
like images i think it works for these
two these are also images
okay so when then when you re-run it
yeah let's run again to see
a little more or less be centered now
yep
yeah
nice
yeah
i was thinking about it should i do this
this might take a while it may not work
i did with one and i was like oh my god
that's so cute you have a little video
in here
[Music]
you